c'est ce qui s'appelle un Paris gagnant
plus de la moitié des salariés de La
Redoute vont toucher à un gros chèque
cent mille euros en moyenne par personne
un joli retour sur investissement pour
les 1500 employés qui ont pris des parts
dans leur entreprise entre 1 et 160
euros
cette valorisation c'est le partage de
la valeur qui a été créé durant toutes
ces années par le travail des
collaborateurs on a cette
multimillionnaire américaine qui dit moi
je me nourris de pâté pour chat pour
faire des effets dans une télé-réalité
aux États-Unis pour voir si on fait les
millionnaires vivent comme nous alors on
dit souvent que l'argent n'a pas d'odeur
mais là à mon avis elle doit avoir une
sacrée bonne haleine notre ami la
multimillionnaire et à mon avis c'est
pas la seule économie qu'elle fait à mon
avis si pour peu qu'elle soit assez
souple je n'ose pas lui demander son
astuce pour faire des économies sur les
produits d'hygiène
bons numéros plus une étoile il boit un
coup vous êtes trop longue parce que
vous voyez bah je dis des trucs hyper
intéressant
en 2014 la marque historique de vente
par correspondance est au bord du
gouffre la redouter CD pour un euro
symbolique assez dirigeants de l'époque
les employés sont invités à participer à
son redressement la majorité d'entre eux
investis entre temps les ventes sur
Internet augmentent et les bénéfices
sont au rendez-vous la Redoute est à
nouveau rentable moins de 10 ans plus
tard les salariés actionnaires se
partagent aujourd'hui 100 millions
d'euros grâce au bon résultat de leur
entreprise moi j'ai été très très mal
accueilli à plusieurs reprises quand
nous avons appelé pour nos amis
précédents et là encore une fois cette
dame pas de sourire pas de bonjour elle
est ferme elle reste dans ses bottes on
va appeler la direction et ça va aucune
raison de se mettre pieds nus pour vous
parler
ses chaussures à chaque fois que vous
appelez calmez-vous
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
on était méchants
[Musique]
on était bouddhiste action réaction en
nous envoyait de la merde en renvoyé de
la merde attention
je sors tu auras envie de discuter
et on en profite pour dire à sa maman de
Jean Collard après toi finalement et
c'est une belle colère
je m'en vais c'est n'importe quoi le
pire classement de l'histoire une
provocation ce qui met ses internautes
dans cet état c'est ce classement des
meilleurs fromages du monde entier
établit selon les votes du site
culinaire test Atlas le trio de tête et
100% italien avec le parmesan le
gorgonzola et la burrata la France est
carrément absente du Top 10 mais non le
premier fromage tricolore est à la 13e
place c'est le reblochon talonné par le
comté plus loin on trouve le Mont d'Or
26e le beaufort à la 31e place le
Neuchâtel à la 33e en fait il y a que
des surprises dans ce classement le
cinquième est un fromage mexicain le wax
saccage je ne connaissais pas tu vois
j'ai ramené des produits de saison c'est
quoi ça
[Rires]
ça vaut en ce moment
où sont des régions où tu es entre 1
euro et 2 euros
alors demi-lune allez toucher votre
demi-lune santé la bien voilà l'autre
demi-lune
la lune alors on fait les jungle allez
bouger la lune que ce soit petit ou gros
c'est la façon de s'en servir non
depuis quelques jours elle a fait des
progrès ouh là là bon je sais pas
comment mais bon Xavier Niel a fait acte
de candidature pour reprendre la
fréquence de M6 il va défendre son
dossier ce matin devant la com il aura
une heure et demie pour convaincre s'il
devait l'emporter et bien il pourrait
créer une toute nouvelle chaîne qui
s'appelle ré la 6 et de leur côté les
Allemands de berthaussmann pourrait
continuer à faire vivre M6 mais plus sur
le sixième canal de la TNT donc
forcément avec moins de téléspectateurs
ce serait un chamboule tout dans le PAF
ce qui font la télé ne croit plus à la
télévision et ben nous si on y croit on
est peut-être les seuls on est peut-être
les derniers Gaulois je regarde la
télévision aujourd'hui je ne vois pas
les mêmes personnes que je vois dans la
rue et c'est un problème
[Musique]
je me vois
c'est quoi cette tête il y a un miroir
dans le pot
je sais pas me regarder parce que moi
bon j'avoue enfin voilà je me regarde
100 fois par jour dans le miroir tu
regardes si on n'a pas des petites
crottes de caca d'œil quelque chose dans
les dents c'est pas important du soir
par semaine avec des fictions originales
françaises le jeudi soir
Emma une soirée du vendredi soir donc
des documentaires et de la musique
passer uniquement des clips à 3h du
matin je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit une
grande preuve d'amour pour la musique
dans la musique
papa
quand la musique
dans la musique
pas
ferme la porte je ferme la porte
il faut
et quand tu la fermes tu la fermes comme
il faut d'accord
et des hommes qui considèrent la
créativité la recherche d'excellence
comme des valeurs cardinales ici c'est
la recherche d'excellence Manu est
critiqué tous les choix éditoriaux quand
même de musique et tout ça et alors
qu'est-ce qu'on question
du groupe c'était une chanson de Goldman
je pense c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'elle
avait la première chanson du groupe la
musique est bonne la musique est bonne
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire mais
je te laisse
la mélodie non mais c'est pas une
critique
mais la mélodie était quand même assez
assez minimaliste on peut on peut se
permettre de leur faire chanter des
choses assez incroyables c'est en ça que
je dis voilà le choix par rapport aux
artistes qui sont présents et toujours
un petit peu en dessous il y a quelqu'un
qui a peur des rails ici ou pas
de souci si je le lance comme ça
[Musique]